PROFESSOR: We're going to
complete our study of WKB
today.
There's a lot of important
things we haven't said yet.
And in particular,
we have not explained
how it all works, really, in
the sense of the connection
formulas.
That's the most non-trivial
part of the WKB story.
And in some ways it's some of
the most interesting things
that you have to
learn from this.
It's an opportunity to learn
something about differential
equation, Fourier
transforms, and the limits
of the quantities you
can really compute.
So we will begin our discussion
with some reconsideration
of these Airy functions.
You've started to
hear about, probably
some in the homework,
some in recitation.
So this relates to this
person, George Biddle
Airy from the Airy
functions, who
lived in England for 90 years.
He was the seventh
Royal Astronomer.
And he was an astronomer
from 1835 to 1881.
Was located, his work
area, in Greenwich.
It's a little bit
outside of London.
And that's where astronomers
were working hard
to establish all the data
associated with the Prime
Meridian.
France also tried to make the
their own meridian the most
important one.
But at the end of
the day, it all
depended of which
astronomers did
the most work in measuring
precise, accurate determination
of times, motion of the
moon, Jupiter's satellites,
all kinds of things that were
pretty important at that time,
especially also
the manufacturing
of good telescopes
and good clocks.
So Mr. Airy also
worked in optics.
And that's where he discovered
these functions we're studying.
And they're very relevant
to the WKB approximation.
So let me remind you a
little of what you've
been considering in the homework
and extend some of those ideas
as well.
So you considered a differential
equation, d 2nd PSI du
squared equal u PSI.
Pretty innocent looking
differential equation.
I'm always surprised how a
differential equation that
looks so simple can
be so intricate.
But anyway, it is.
And that's the Airy equation.
And it shows up for this problem
that you have, for example,
an infinite wall and a
potential goes up like that.
The bound states are controlled
by solutions of this equation
at the end of the day.
This is after you clean up all
the units and do all the work.
But it shows in
other places as well.
And you probably found already
that this PSI function, PSI
of u, is given as a constant
times an integral that
came from Fourier
transformations of e
to the ik cubed
over 3 e to the iku.
And so this is our integral.
This is our solution
of this equation.
And the nice thing is that
this integral tells you
a lot about the function.
It's a perfectly nice
definition of the function.
You may have
noticed, and I think
it was discussed to some
degree in recitation
as well, that the Fourier
transform converts
this equation to first
order differential equation.
Because this becomes
p squared times PSI.
Well, you know from
Schrodinger equations
this part of the differential
equation comes from p squared.
On the other hand,
multiplication by x
is the same as dvp
in Fourier space.
Therefore, you get
the dvp of PSI equal p
squared PSI equation.
And that equation is a first
order differential equation.
First order differential
equations have one solution.
So you would say, OK, I tried
to do this by Fourier transform,
and I'm getting just
half of the solutions.
And that's true.
The reason is that the other
solution of this differential
equation doesn't quite
have a Fourier transform,
so it's a little more
difficult to get at.
But once you think
of this integral,
it is kind of useful to try
to be a little more general
and think of it in terms of the
complex plane, the complex k
plane.
So here is the k plane.
And this integral is over k
from minus infinity to infinity.
So this is the standard
countour of integration.
We can call it the countour c1.
When you're doing this
integral, and you're
doing this in the
complex plane you
may want to consider that
if you go off the real line,
maybe things are even better.
In particular, as
you're integrating
u is a fixed number,
it's a fixed coordinate.
We usually think of u
as real, but we could
think of u as complex as well.
And this integral
has these factories.
It's an oscillatory factor
that becomes faster and faster
oscillating in time.
But the magnitude of the
integrand is 1 at every place.
It oscillates very fast,
but the magnitude is 1.
Not the best situation possible.
You know?
When you're doing
an integral, you
have the feeling
that eventually you
get 0 because it's
oscillating so fast.
But it would be nicer
if you had a decay.
So for that, consider
that this function
would be k if k, if the
imaginary part of k cube,
is positive, the ky.
If the imaginary part of k cube
is positive, you have a k cube
would be i times a positive
number. i items i is minus 1,
so you get the
suppression factor,
if the imaginary part
of k cube is positive.
So if you're integrating
over a region
where the imaginary part
of k cube is positive,
you will be in good shape.
Now, if you think of k
as a complex number, e
to the i theta k, k
cube would be this.
An imaginary part of k
cube is positive requires
that this angle 3i theta
k be between pi and 0.
Why?
Because if you have a complex
number, any complex number,
its imaginary part is positive
if the argument of that angle
goes between 0 and pi.
Moreover, if you get
an imaginary part
positive for some angle
theta k, if m of k cube
is positive for some
theta k, it is also
positive for theta
k plus 2pi over 3.
Because if you add 2
pi over 3 to theta k,
you change this by 2pi.
And therefore, the
exponential doesn't change.
From this inequality, I'm sorry,
I have an i too many here.
The imaginary part
of this requires
that the argument of
this be between 0 and pi,
or theta k between
pi over 3 and 0.
So actually, here, I
should draw 0 to pi over 3.
This is at 60 degrees.
And that's the region
in k space where
the integral is suppressed.
Now, we also said that
this region is unchanged
if you add 2pi over 3.
So if I add 2pi over 3, that's
precisely 1/3 of a turn.
This is 30 degrees.
It goes this area into this.
And finally, if I add,
again, 2pi over 3,
it goes into 30, 30,
30, and to this region.
I guess the sign of nuclear
material, hazardous materials
or something that.
It's not hazardous
to our health.
We'll survive this lecture.
So what's happening
here actually
is something quite interesting.
For example, you're
doing this integral here.
If you started
doing this integral,
once you are far, far
away, you start going up,
the integral over here
is going to give nothing,
because you're very far away.
And therefore,
you're in the region
of absolute exponential
suppression.
We said this thing has a
positive imaginary part.
And therefore, you
have a suppression.
It's k cubed, so
it's becoming like e
to the minus radius cubed.
It's killed.
So it's no problem to go up
here, and you get nothing.
So what it means is
that actually there's
no singularities in
the integrand either.
This integral that
we've done here
could have been done over
this contour like that.
And then you could
have gone like that.
You could do it in Mathematica.
The answer will be the same.
Or you could have
gone like that.
gone here like this,
also you're
suppressed over here.
And you're suppressed over here.
And actually, by contouring
the formation, you could
instead of doing
this in theory, you
could have come here
and gone up like that.
And done that.
That also would have been the
same result. There's nothing,
the integrand is analytic here.
So this you can push it
down and nothing goes wrong.
Or you could have done even
this integral like that.
Because the integral here is
0 and the integral here is 0,
so you can bring them down.
In fact, if you
did this, I think,
with Mathematica,
Mathematica when
you try to do this
integral, kind of does it.
But it complains a little.
It's worried that,
you know, it's
not getting the answer right
because the integrand is still
big.
It's oscillating very
fast, but it's big.
If you go here, I think
Mathematica will complain less
and will give you
the same answer.
So this is the power
of complex analysis
that allows you to do this
integral in all kinds of ways.
And there is something even
more important about this
that I will explain
in the notes,
but I can convey the idea here.
When you prove that
this is a solution,
and when you went
to Fourier space,
you had to do an
integration by parts.
And an integration by
parts is always dangerous.
And if you're trying to find a
true solution of your problem,
you have to make sure it works.
P, the operator P, is
supposed to be her mission.
And here what happens is
that you turn this into dvp.
And you have to fall
back this factor.
And here is where this
discussion is very relevant.
Because when you fold out this
factor, you have to integrate.
You couldn't get contributions
from the boundary.
And you have to make sure
those contributions are 0.
Otherwise, you're not solving
the differential equation
really.
And the happy thing
about these contours,
and now that you
understand these regions,
is that, yes, the
boundary contributions
are going to be 0 from
the two sides because
of this suppression factor.
So this analysis actually turns
it into a rigorous analysis.
And the part that has
to do with the boundary
conditions, the fact that the
operations that you're doing
are illegal when you try
to solve the differential
equation, require--
this is the details that
I will not derive now--
require precisely that e to the
i k cubed over 3 e to the iku
vanish at the ends of
the countour gamma that
you're using to
solve the problem.
So if you're in the
wave from here to here,
it should vanish at this
end and at that end.
Rigorously speaking,
this thing only
vanishes if you're
a little bit up.
But this is what you really
need for the equation
to be a solution.